The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So let's get started.
So today, we're
going to be talking
about races and parallelism.
And you'll be doing a lot
of parallel programming
for the next homework
assignment and project.
One thing I want to point
out is that it's important
to meet with your MITPOSSE
as soon as possible,
if you haven't done so
already, since that's
going to be part of the
evaluation for the Project 1
grade.
And if you have trouble
reaching your MITPOSSE members,
please contact your TA and
also make a post on Piazza
as soon as possible.
So as a reminder, let's
look at the basics of Cilk.
So we have cilk_spawn
and cilk_sync statements.
In Cilk, this was
the code that we
saw in last lecture, which
computes the nth Fibonacci
number.
So when we say
cilk_spawn, it means
that the named child
function, the function right
after the cilk_spawn keyword,
can execute in parallel
with the parent caller.
So it says that fib
of n minus 1 can
execute in parallel with the
fib function that called it.
And then cilk_sync says that
control cannot pass this point
until all of this spawned
children have returned.
So this is going to wait
for fib of n minus 1
to finish before it goes on
and returns the sum of x and y.
And recall that the Cilk
keywords grant permission
for parallel execution,
but they don't actually
force parallel execution.
So this code here says that we
can execute fib of n minus 1
in parallel with
this parent caller,
but it doesn't say that
we necessarily have
to execute them in parallel.
And it's up to
the runtime system
to decide whether these
different functions will
be executed in parallel.
We'll talk more about
the runtime system today.
And also, we talked
about this example,
where we wanted to do an
in-place matrix transpose.
And this used the
cilk_for keyword.
And this says that
we can execute
the iterations of this
cilk_for loop in parallel.
And again, this says
that the runtime system
is allowed to schedule these
iterations in parallel,
but doesn't necessarily
say that they
have to execute in parallel.
And under the hood,
cilk_for statements
are translated into nested
cilk_spawn and cilk_sync calls.
So the compiler is going
to divide the iteration
space in half, do a cilk_spawn
on one of the two halves,
call the other
half, and then this
is done recursively
until we reach
a certain size for the
number of iterations
in a loop, at
which point it just
creates a single task for that.
So any questions on
the Cilk constructs?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is Cilk smart
enough to recognize issues
with reading and writing
for matrix transpose?
JULIAN SHUN: So
it's actually not
going to figure out
whether the iterations are
independent for you.
The programmer actually
has to reason about that.
But Cilk does have a nice
tool, which we'll talk about,
that will tell you which
places your code might possibly
be reading and writing
the same memory location,
and that allows you to
localize any possible race
bugs in your code.
So we'll actually
talk about races.
But if you just
compile this code,
Cilk isn't going to know whether
the iterations are independent.
So determinacy races--
so race conditions
are the bane of concurrency.
So you don't want to have
race conditions in your code.
And there are these two famous
race bugs that cause disaster.
So there is this Therac-25
radiation therapy machine,
and there was a race
condition in the software.
And this led to three
people being killed
and many more being
seriously injured.
The North American
blackout of 2003
was also caused by a
race bug in the software,
and this left 50 million
people without power.
So these are very bad.
And they're notoriously
difficult to discover
by conventional testing.
So race bugs aren't going
to appear every time
you execute your program.
And in fact, the hardest ones to
find, which cause these events,
are actually very rare events.
So most of the times when
you run your program,
you're not going to
see the race bug.
Only very rarely
will you see it.
So this makes it very hard
to find these race bugs.
And furthermore, when
you see a race bug,
it doesn't necessarily
always happen
in the same place in your code.
So that makes it even harder.
So what is a race?
So a determinacy race is one of
the most basic forms of races.
And a determinacy
race occurs when
two logically
parallel instructions
access the same memory
location, and at least one
of these instructions performs
a write to that location.
So let's look at
a simple example.
So in this code here, I'm
first setting x equal to 0.
And then I have a cilk_for
loop with two iterations,
and each of the
two iterations are
incrementing this variable x.
And then at the end, I'm going
to assert that x is equal to 2.
So there's actually a
race in this program here.
So in order to understand
where the race occurs,
let's look at the
execution graph here.
So I'm going to label each of
these statements with a letter.
The first statement, a, is
just setting x equal to 0.
And then after
that, we're actually
going to have two
parallel paths, because we
have two iterations of
this cilk_for loop, which
can execute in parallel.
And each of these paths are
going to increment x by 1.
And then finally, we're going
to assert that x is equal to 2
at the end.
And this sort of graph is
known as a dependency graph.
It tells you what
instructions have
to finish before you execute
the next instruction.
So here it says
that B and C must
wait for A to execute
before they proceed,
but B and C can actually happen
in parallel, because there
is no dependency among them.
And then D has to happen
after B and C finish.
So to understand why
there's a race bug here,
we actually need to
take a closer look
at this dependency graph.
So let's take a closer look.
So when you run this
code, x plus plus
is actually going to be
translated into three steps.
So first, we're going
to load the value
of x into some
processor's register, r1.
And then we're going
to increment r1,
and then we're going to set
x equal to the result of r1.
And the same thing for r2.
We're going to load x into
register r2, increment r2,
and then set x equal to r2.
So here, we have a race,
because both of these stores,
x1 equal to r1 and
x2 equal to r2,
are actually writing to
the same memory location.
So let's look at one possible
execution of this computation
graph.
And we're going to keep track
of the values of x, r1 and r2.
So the first instruction
we're going to execute
is x equal to 0.
So we just set x equal to 0,
and everything's good so far.
And then next, we can actually
pick one of two instructions
to execute, because both
of these two instructions
have their predecessors
satisfied already.
Their predecessors
have already executed.
So let's say I pick r1
equal to x to execute.
And this is going to place
the value 0 into register r1.
Now I'm going to
increment r1, so this
changes the value in r1 to 1.
Then now, let's say I
execute r2 equal to x.
So that's going to read
x, which has a value of 0.
It's going to place
the value of 0 into r2.
It's going to increment r2.
That's going to change
that value to 1.
And then now, let's say
I write r2 back to x.
So I'm going to place
a value of 1 into x.
Then now, when I execute this
instruction, x1 equal to r1,
it's also placing a
value of 1 into x.
And then finally, when
I do the assertion,
this value here is not equal
to 2, and that's wrong.
Because if you executed
this sequentially,
you would get a value of 2 here.
And the reason-- as I said,
the reason why this occurs
is because we have
multiple writes
to the same shared
memory location, which
could execute in parallel.
And one of the nasty
things about this example
here is that the race bug
doesn't necessarily always
occur.
So does anyone see why this
race bug doesn't necessarily
always show up?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So the answer is because if
one of these two branches
executes all three
of its instructions
before we start the other one,
then the final result in x
is going to be 2,
which is correct.
So if I executed
these instructions
in order of 1, 2, 3, 7, 4, 5, 6,
and then, finally, 8, the value
is going to be 2 in x.
So the race bug here doesn't
necessarily always occur.
And this is one thing that
makes these bugs hard to find.
So any questions?
So there are two different
types of determinacy races.
And they're shown
in this table here.
So let's suppose that
instruction A and instruction
B both access some location x,
and suppose A is parallel to B.
So both of the instructions
can execute in parallel.
So if A and B are just
reading that location,
then that's fine.
You don't actually
have a race here.
But if one of the
two instructions
is writing to that location,
whereas the other one is
reading to that
location, then you
have what's called a read race.
And the program might have
a non-deterministic result
when you have a read race,
because the final answer might
depend on whether you
read A first before B
updated the value, or
whether A read the updated
value before B reads it.
So the order of the
execution of A and B
can affect the final
result that you see.
And finally, if
both A and B write
to the same shared location,
then you have a write race.
And again, this will cause
non-deterministic behavior
in your program, because the
final answer could depend on
whether A did the write first
or B did the write first.
And we say that two
sections of code
are independent if there are no
determinacy races between them.
So the two pieces of code
can't have a shared location,
where one computation
writes to it
and another computation
reads from it,
or if both computations
write to that location.
Any questions on the definition?
So races are really bad,
and you should avoid
having races in your program.
So here are some tips
on how to avoid races.
So I can tell you not to
write races in your program,
and you know that races
are bad, but sometimes,
when you're writing
code, you just
have races in your program,
and you can't help it.
But here are some tips on
how you can avoid races.
So first, the iterations
of a cilk_for loop
should be independent.
So you should make sure that
the different iterations
of a cilk_for loop aren't
writing to the same memory
location.
Secondly, between a
cilk_spawn statement
and a corresponding cilk_sync,
the code of the spawn child
should be independent of
the code of the parent.
And this includes code that's
executed by additional spawned
or called children
by the spawned child.
So you should make sure
that these pieces of code
are independent--
there's no read
or write races between them.
One thing to note is that the
arguments to a spawn function
are evaluated in the parent
before the spawn actually
occurs.
So you can't get a race in
the argument evaluation,
because the parent is going
to evaluate these arguments.
And there's only one
thread that's doing this,
so it's fine.
And another thing to note
is that the machine word
size matters.
So you need to
watch out for races
when you're reading and writing
to packed data structures.
So here's an example.
I have a struct x with
two chars, a and b.
And updating x.a and x.b
may possibly cause a race.
And this is a nasty
race, because it
depends on the compiler
optimization level.
Fortunately, this is safe
on the Intel machines
that we're using in this class.
You can't get a race
in this example.
But there are
other architectures
that might have a race when
you're updating the two
variables a and b in this case.
So with the Intel
machines that we're
using, if you're using standard
data types like chars, shorts,
ints, and longs inside a
struct, you won't get races.
But if you're using
non-standard types--
for example, you're using
the C bit fields facilities,
and the sizes of the fields are
not one of the standard sizes,
then you could
possibly get a race.
In particular, if you're
updating individual bits
inside a word in parallel, then
you might see a race there.
So you need to be careful.
Questions?
So fortunately,
the Cilk platform
has a very nice
tool called the--
yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] was going
to ask, what causes that race?
JULIAN SHUN: Because the
architecture might actually
be updating this struct
at the granularity of more
than 1 byte.
So if you're updating single
bytes inside this larger word,
then that might cause a race.
But fortunately, this doesn't
happen on Intel machines.
So the Cilksan race detector--
if you compile your
code using this flag,
minus f sanitize
equal to cilk, then
it's going to generate a
Cilksan instrumentive program.
And then if an ostensibly
deterministic Cilk program
run on a given input could
possibly behave any differently
than its serial
elision, then Cilksan
is going to guarantee
to report and localize
the offending race.
So Cilksan is going to tell
you which memory location there
might be a race on and
which of the instructions
were involved in this race.
So Cilksan employs a
regression test methodology
where the programmer provides
it different test inputs.
And for each test input,
if there could possibly
be a race in the program, then
it will report these races.
And it identifies the
file names, the lines,
the variables
involved in the races,
including the stack traces.
So it's very helpful when
you're trying to debug your code
and find out where there's
a race in your program.
One thing to note
is that you should
ensure that all of your
program files are instrumented.
Because if you only instrument
some of your files and not
the other ones, then
you'll possibly miss out
on some of these race bugs.
And one of the nice things
about the Cilksan race detector
is that it's always going
to report a race if there
is possibly a race, unlike many
other race detectors, which
are best efforts.
So they might report a
race some of the times
when the race actually occurs,
but they don't necessarily
report a race all the time.
Because in some executions,
the race doesn't occur.
But the Cilksan race
detector is going
to always report the race,
if there is potentially
a race in there.
Cilksan is your best friend.
So use this when you're
debugging your homeworks
and projects.
Here's an example of the output
that's generated by Cilksan.
So you can see that it's saying
that there's a race detected
at this memory address here.
And the line of code
that caused this race
is shown here, as
well as the file name.
So this is a matrix
multiplication example.
And then it also tells you
how many races it detected.
So any questions on
determinacy races?
So let's now talk
about parallelism.
So what is parallelism?
Can we quantitatively
define what parallelism is?
So what does it mean
when somebody tells you
that their code is
highly parallel?
So to have a formal
definition of parallelism,
we first need to look at
the Cilk execution model.
So this is a code that we
saw before for Fibonacci.
Let's now look at what a
call to fib of 4 looks like.
So here, I've color coded the
different lines of code here
so that I can refer
to them when I'm
drawing this computation graph.
So now, I'm going to draw this
computation graph corresponding
to how the computation
unfolds during execution.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to call fib of 4.
And that's going to
generate this magenta node
here corresponding to
the call to fib of 4,
and that's going to represent
this pink code here.
And this illustration is similar
to the computation graphs
that you saw in the
previous lecture,
but this is happening
in parallel.
And I'm only labeling
the argument here,
but you could actually also
write the local variables
there.
But I didn't do it, because
I want to fit everything
on this slide.
So what happens when
you call fib of 4?
It's going to get to this
cilk_spawn statement,
and then it's going
to call fib of 3.
And when I get to a cilk_spawn
statement, what I do
is I'm going to create
another node that corresponds
to the child that I spawned.
So this is this magenta
node here in this blue box.
And then I also
have a continue edge
going to a green node that
represents the computation
after the cilk_spawn statement.
So this green node here
corresponds to the green line
of code in the code snippet.
Now I can unfold this
computation graph
one more step.
So we see that fib 3 is
going to call fib of 2,
so I created another node here.
And the green node
here, which corresponds
to this green line
of code-- it's
also going to make
a function call.
It's going to call fib of 2.
And that's also going
to create a new node.
So in general,
when I do a spawn,
I'm going to have two outgoing
edges out of a magenta node.
And when I do a call, I'm going
to have one outgoing edge out
of a green node.
So this green node,
the outgoing edge
corresponds to a function call.
And for this magenta node,
its first outgoing edge
corresponds to spawn, and
then its second outgoing edge
goes to the continuation strand.
So I can unfold
this one more time.
And here, I see that I'm
creating some more spawns
and calls to fib.
And if I do this
one more time, I've
actually reached the base case.
Because once n is
equal to 1 or 0,
I'm not going to make
any more recursive calls.
And by the way, the color of
these boxes that I used here
correspond to whether
I called that function
or whether I spawned it.
So a box with white background
corresponds to a function
that I called, whereas a
box with blue background
corresponds to a
function that I spawned.
So now I've gotten
to the base case,
I need to now execute
this blue statement, which
sums up x and y and returns the
result to the parent caller.
So here I have a blue node.
So this is going to take
the results of the two
recursive calls,
sum them together.
And I have another
blue node here.
And then it's going
to pass its value
to the parent that called it.
So I'm going to pass
this up to its parent,
and then I'm going to
pass this one up as well.
And finally, I have a blue
node at the top level, which
is going to compute
my final result,
and that's going to be
the output of the program.
So one thing to note is
that this computation dag
unfolds dynamically
during the execution.
So the runtime
system isn't going
to create this graph
at the beginning.
It's actually going to
create this on the fly
as you run the program.
So this graph here
unfolds dynamically.
And also, this graph here
is processor-oblivious.
So nowhere in this
computation dag
did I mention the
number of processors
I had for the computation.
And similarly, in the
code here, I never
mentioned the number of
processors that I'm using.
So the runtime system
is going to figure out
how to map these tasks to
the number of processors
that you give to the computation
dynamically at runtime.
So for example, I can run this
on any number of processors.
If I run it on one
processor, it's
just going to execute
these tasks in parallel.
In fact, it's going
to execute them
in a depth-first order,
which corresponds to the what
the sequential
algorithm would do.
So I'm going to start with fib
of 4, go to fib of 3, fib of 2,
fib of 1, and go pop back
up and then do fib of 0
and go back up and so on.
So if I use one
processor, it's going
to create and execute
this computation
dag in the depth-first manner.
And if I have more
than one processor,
it's not necessarily going to
follow a depth-first order,
because I could have multiple
computations going on.
Any questions on this example?
I'm actually going to
formally define some terms
on the next slide so that
we can formalize the notion
of a computation dag.
So dag stands for
directed acyclic graph,
and this is a directed
acyclic graph.
So we call it a computation dag.
So a parallel
instruction stream is
a dag G with vertices
V and edges E.
And each vertex in this dag
corresponds to a strand.
And a strand is a
sequence of instructions
not containing a spawn, a
sync, or a return from a spawn.
So the instructions
inside a strand
are executed sequentially.
There's no parallelism
within a strand.
We call the first strand
the initial strand,
so this is the
magenta node up here.
The last strand-- we
call it the final strand.
And then everything else,
we just call it a strand.
And then there are
four types of edges.
So there are spawn edges,
call edges, return edges,
or continue edges.
And a spawn edge corresponds
to an edge to a function
that you spawned.
So these spawn edges are
going to go to a magenta node.
A call edge corresponds to an
edge that goes to a function
that you called.
So in this example, these are
coming out of the green nodes
and going to a magenta node.
A return edge corresponds
to an edge going back up
to the parent caller.
So here, it's going into
one of these blue nodes.
And then finally, a continue
edge is just the other edge
when you spawn a function.
So this is the edge that
goes to the green node.
It's representing
the computation
after you spawn something.
And notice that in
this computation dag,
we never explicitly
represented cilk_for,
because as I said
before, cilk_fors
are converted to
nested cilk_spawns
and cilk_sync statements.
So we don't actually need to
explicitly represent cilk_fors
in the computation DAG.
Any questions on
this definition?
So we're going to be
using this computation
dag throughout this lecture to
analyze how much parallelism
there is in a program.
So assuming that each of these
strands executes in unit time--
this assumption isn't
always true in practice.
In practice, strands will take
different amounts of time.
But let's assume,
for simplicity,
that each strand
here takes unit time.
Does anyone want to guess
what the parallelism
of this computation is?
So how parallel do
you think this is?
What's the maximum speedup you
might get on this computation?
AUDIENCE: 5.
JULIAN SHUN: 5.
Somebody said 5.
Any other guesses?
Who thinks this is going
to be less than five?
A couple people.
Who thinks it's going
to be more than five?
A couple of people.
Who thinks there's
any parallelism
at all in this computation?
Yeah, seems like a lot of people
think there is some parallelism
here.
So we're actually going to
analyze how much parallelism
is in this computation.
So I'm not going to
tell you the answer now,
but I'll tell you in
a couple of slides.
First need to go over
some terminology.
So whenever you start
talking about parallelism,
somebody is almost always
going to bring up Amdahl's Law.
And Amdahl's Law says that
if 50% of your application
is parallel and the
other 50% is serial,
then you can't get more
than a factor of 2 speedup,
no matter how many processors
you run the computation on.
Does anyone know why
this is the case?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because you need it
to execute for at least 50%
of the time in order to get
through the serial portion.
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So you have to
spend at least 50%
of the time in the
serial portion.
So in the best
case, if I gave you
an infinite number
of processors,
and you can reduce the
parallel portion of your code
to 0 running time, you still
have the 50% of the serial time
that you have to execute.
And therefore, the best speedup
you can get is a factor of 2.
And in general, if a fraction
alpha of an application
must be run serially, then
the speedup can be at most 1
over alpha.
So if 1/3 of your program has
to be executed sequentially,
then the speedup
can be, at most, 3.
Because even if you reduce the
parallel portion of your code
to tab a running
time of 0, you still
have the sequential part of your
code that you have to wait for.
So let's try to quantify the
parallelism in this computation
here.
So how many of these nodes have
to be executed sequentially?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 9 of them.
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns
out to be less than 9.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 7.
JULIAN SHUN: 7.
It turns out to be less than 7.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 6.
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns
out to be less than 6.
AUDIENCE: 4.
JULIAN SHUN: Turns
out to be less than 4.
You're getting close.
AUDIENCE: 2.
JULIAN SHUN: 2.
So turns out to be more than 2.
AUDIENCE: 2.5.
JULIAN SHUN: What's left?
AUDIENCE: 3.
JULIAN SHUN: 3.
OK.
So 3 of these nodes have to
be executed sequentially.
Because when you're
executing these nodes,
there's nothing else that
can happen in parallel.
For all of the remaining nodes,
when you're executing them,
you can potentially
be executing some
of the other nodes in parallel.
But for these three nodes
that I've colored in yellow,
you have to execute
those sequentially,
because there's nothing else
that's going on in parallel.
So according to
Amdahl's Law, this
says that the serial fraction
of the program is 3 over 18.
So there's 18 nodes
in this graph here.
So therefore, the serial
factor is 1 over 6,
and the speedup is upper bound
by 1 over that, which is 6.
So Amdahl's Law tells us that
the maximum speedup we can get
is 6.
Any questions on how I
got this number here?
So it turns out that Amdahl's
Law actually gives us
a pretty loose upper
bound on the parallelism,
and it's not that useful
in many practical cases.
So we're actually going
to look at a better
definition of parallelism
that will give us
a better upper bound on the
maximum speedup we can get.
So we're going to define T
sub P to be the execution time
of the program on P processors.
And T sub 1 is just the work.
So T sub 1 is if you executed
this program on one processor,
how much stuff do
you have to do?
And we define that
to be the work.
Recall in lecture 2,
we looked at many ways
to optimize the work.
This is the work term.
So in this example,
the number of nodes
here is 18, so the work
is just going to be 18.
We also define T of
infinity to be the span.
The span is also called
the critical path
length, or the computational
depth, of the graph.
And this is equal to the
longest directed path
you can find in this graph.
So in this example,
the longest path is 9.
So one of the students
answered 9 earlier,
and this is actually
the span of this graph.
So there are 9 nodes
along this path here,
and that's the longest
one you can find.
And we call this T of infinity
because that's actually
the execution time
of this program
if you had an infinite
number of processors.
So there are two
laws that are going
to relate these quantities.
So the work law
says that T sub P
is greater than or equal
to T sub 1 divided by P.
So this says that the
execution time on P processors
has to be greater than
or equal to the work
of the program divided by the
number of processors you have.
Does anyone see why
the work law is true?
So the answer is that if you
have P processors, on each time
stub, you can do,
at most, P work.
So if you multiply
both sides by P,
you get P times T sub P is
greater than or equal to T1.
If P times T sub P
was less than T1, then
that means you're not
done with the computation,
because you haven't
done all the work yet.
So the work law
says that T sub P
has to be greater than
or equal to T1 over P.
Any questions on the work law?
So let's look at another law.
This is called the span law.
It says that T sub P has to be
greater than or equal to T sub
infinity.
So the execution
time on P processors
has to be at least execution
time on an infinite number
of processors.
Anyone know why the
span law has to be true?
So another way to see
this is that if you
had an infinite
number of processors,
you can actually simulate
a P processor system.
You just use P of the
processors and leave all
the remaining processors idle.
And that can't slow
down your program.
So therefore, you
have that T sub P
has to be greater than or
equal to T sub infinity.
If you add more
processors to it,
the running time can't go up.
Any questions?
So let's see how we
can compose the work
and the span quantities
of different computations.
So let's say I have two
computations, A and B.
And let's say that A
has to execute before B.
So everything in
A has to be done
before I start the
computation in B. Let's say
I know what the work of A and
the work of B individually are.
What would be the
work of A union B?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I guess it
would be T1 A plus T1 B.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So why is that?
AUDIENCE: Well, you have
to execute sequentially.
So then you just take the time
and [INAUDIBLE] execute A,
then it'll execute B after that.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the work is just going to
be the sum of the work of A
and the work of B. Because you
have to do all of the work of A
and then do all
of the work of B,
so you just add them together.
What about the span?
So let's say I
know the span of A
and I know the span of B.
What's the span of A union B?
So again, it's just a sum of
the span of A and the span of B.
This is because I have
to execute everything
in A before I start B. So I
just sum together the spans.
So this is series composition.
What if I do
parallel composition?
So let's say here,
I'm executing the two
computations in parallel.
What's the work of A union B?
So it's not it's not
going to be the maximum.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It should still
be T1 of A plus T1 of B.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so it's still going
to be the sum of T1
of A and T1 of B.
Because you still have
the same amount of work
that you have to do.
It's just that you're
doing it in parallel.
But the work is just the time
if you had one processor.
So if you had one
processor, you wouldn't
be executing these in parallel.
What about the span?
So if I know the span
of A and the span of B,
what's the span of the parallel
composition of the two?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
the span of A union B
is going to be the max of the
span of A and the span of B,
because I'm going
to be bottlenecked
by the slower of the
two computations.
So I just take the one
that has longer span,
and that gives me
the overall span.
Any questions?
So here's another definition.
So T1 divided by TP is the
speedup on P processors.
If I have T1 divided
by TP less than P, then
this means that I have
sub-linear speedup.
I'm not making use of
all the processors.
Because I'm using P
processors, but I'm not
getting a speedup of P.
If T1 over TP is
equal to P, then I'm
getting perfect linear speedup.
I'm making use of
all of my processors.
I'm putting P times as many
resources into my computation,
and it becomes P times faster.
So this is the good case.
And finally, if T1 over
TP is greater than P,
we have something called
superlinear speedup.
In our simple
performance model, this
can't actually happen,
because of the work law.
The work law says that TP has
to be at least T1 divided by P.
So if you rearrange
the terms, you'll
see that we get a
contradiction in our model.
In practice, you might sometimes
see that you have a superlinear
speedup, because when you're
using more processors,
you might have
access to more cache,
and that could improve the
performance of your program.
But in general, you might see
a little bit of superlinear
speedup, but not that much.
And in our simplified
model, we're
just going to assume that
you can't have a superlinear
speedup.
And getting perfect linear
speedup is already very good.
So because the span law says
that TP has to be at least T
infinity, the maximum
possible speedup
is just going to be T1
divided by T infinity,
and that's the parallelism
of your computation.
This is a maximum possible
speedup you can get.
Another way to view
this is that it's
equal to the average
amount of work
that you have to do per
step along the span.
So for every step
along the span,
you're doing this much work.
And after all the steps, then
you've done all of the work.
So what's the parallelism of
this computation dag here?
AUDIENCE: 2.
JULIAN SHUN: 2.
Why is it 2?
AUDIENCE: T1 is 18
and T infinity is 9.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So T1 is 18.
There are 18 nodes
in this graph.
T infinity is 9.
And the last time I checked,
18 divided by 9 is 2.
So the parallelism here is 2.
So now we can go back to
our Fibonacci example,
and we can also analyze the
work and the span of this
and compute the
maximum parallelism.
So again, for
simplicity, let's assume
that each of these strands
takes unit time to execute.
Again, in practice, that's
not necessarily true.
But for simplicity,
let's just assume that.
So what's the work
of this computation?
AUDIENCE: 17.
JULIAN SHUN: 17.
Right.
So the work is just
the number of nodes
you have in this graph.
And you can just count
that up, and you get 17.
What about the span?
Somebody said 8.
Yeah, so the span is 8.
And here's the longest path.
So this is the path
that has 8 nodes in it,
and that's the longest
one you can find here.
So therefore, the
parallelism is just 17
divided by 8, which is 2.125.
And so for all of you who
guessed that the parallelism
was 2, you were very close.
This tells us that using
many more than two processors
can only yield us marginal
performance gains.
Because the maximum speedup
we can get is 2.125.
So we throw eight processors
at this computation,
we're not going to get
a speedup beyond 2.125.
So to figure out
how much parallelism
is in your computation,
you need to analyze
the work of your computation
and the span of your computation
and then take the ratio
between the two quantities.
But for large computations,
it's actually pretty tedious
to analyze this by hand.
You don't want to
draw these things out
by hand for a very
large computation.
And fortunately, Cilk has
a tool called the Cilkscale
Scalability Analyzer.
So this is integrated into
the Tapir/LLVM compiler
that you'll be using
for this course.
And Cilkscale uses
compiler instrumentation
to analyze a serial
execution of a program,
and it's going to generate the
work and the span quantities
and then use those
quantities to derive
upper bounds on the parallel
speedup of your program.
So you'll have a
chance to play around
with Cilkscale in homework 4.
So let's try to analyze the
parallelism of quicksort.
And here, we're using a
parallel quicksort algorithm.
The function quicksort
here takes two inputs.
These are two pointers.
Left points to the beginning of
the array that we want to sort.
Right points to one element
after the end of the array.
And what we do is we first
check if left is equal to right.
If so, then we just return,
because there are no elements
to sort.
Otherwise, we're going to
call this partition function.
The partition function is
going to pick a random pivot--
so this is a randomized
quicksort algorithm--
and then it's going to
move everything that's
less than the pivot to
the left part of the array
and everything
that's greater than
or equal to the pivot to
the right part of the array.
It's also going to return
us a pointer to the pivot.
And then now we can execute
two recursive calls.
So we do quicksort on the
left side and quicksort
on the right side.
And this can happen in parallel.
So we use the cilk_spawn here
to spawn off one of these calls
to quicksort in parallel.
And therefore, the two
recursive calls are parallel.
And then finally,
we sync up before we
return from the function.
So let's say we wanted
to sort 1 million numbers
with this quicksort algorithm.
And let's also assume that
the partition function here
is written sequentially,
so you have
to go through all of the
elements, one by one.
Can anyone guess
what the parallelism
is in this computation?
AUDIENCE: 1 million.
JULIAN SHUN: So the
guess was 1 million.
Any other guesses?
AUDIENCE: 50,000.
JULIAN SHUN: 50,000.
Any other guesses?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 2.
JULIAN SHUN: 2.
It's a good guess.
AUDIENCE: Log 2 of a million.
JULIAN SHUN: Log
base 2 of a million.
Any other guesses?
So log base 2 of a million,
2, 50,000, and 1 million.
Anyone think it's
more than 1 million?
No.
So no takers on
more than 1 million.
So if you run this
program using Cilkscale,
it will generate a plot
that looks like this.
And there are several
lines on this plot.
So let's talk about what
each of these lines mean.
So this purple line
here is the speedup
that you observe
in your computation
when you're running it.
And you can get that by
taking the single processor
running time and dividing
it by the running
time on P processors.
So this is the observed speedup.
That's the purple line.
The blue line here is the line
that you get from the span law.
So this is T1 over T infinity.
And here, this gives us a bound
of about 6 for the parallelism.
The green line is the
bound from the work law.
So this is just a linear
line with a slope of 1.
It says that on
P processors, you
can't get more than a
factor of P speedup.
So therefore, the maximum
speedup you can get
has to be below the green
line and below the blue line.
So you're in this lower
right quadrant of the plot.
There's also this
orange line, which
is the speedup you would get
if you used a greedy scheduler.
We'll talk more about
the greedy scheduler
later on in this lecture.
So this is the plot
that you would get.
And we see here that the
maximum speedup is about 5.
So for those of you who guessed
2 and log base 2 of a million,
you were the closest.
You can also
generate a plot that
just tells you the execution
time versus the number
of processors.
And you can get
this quite easily
just by doing a
simple transformation
from the previous plot.
So Cilkscale is going to give
you these useful plots that you
can use to figure out how much
parallelism is in your program.
And let's see why the
parallelism here is so low.
So I said that we were going
to execute this partition
function sequentially,
and it turns out
that that's actually the
bottleneck to the parallelism.
So the expected work of
quicksort is order n log n.
So some of you
might have seen this
in your previous
algorithms courses.
If you haven't seen
this yet, then you
can take a look at your
favorite textbook, Introduction
to Algorithms.
It turns out that the
parallel version of quicksort
also has an expected work
bound of order n log n,
if you pick a random pivot.
So the analysis is similar.
The expected span bound
turns out to be at least n.
And this is because on the
first level of recursion,
we have to call this
partition function, which
is going to go through
the elements one by one.
So that already
has a linear span.
And it turns out that the
overall span is also order n,
because the span
actually works out
to be a geometrically decreasing
sequence and sums to order n.
And therefore, the maximum
parallelism you can get
is order log n.
So you just take the
work divided by the span.
So for the student who guessed
that the parallelism is log
base 2 of n, that's very good.
Turns out that it's
not exactly log base
2 of n, because there are
constants in these work
and span bounds, so it's
on the order of log of n.
That's the parallelism.
And it turns out that order log
n parallelism is not very high.
In general, you want the
parallelism to be much higher,
something polynomial in n.
And in order to get
more parallelism
in this algorithm,
what you have to do
is you have to
parallelize this partition
function, because
right now I I'm
just executing
this sequentially.
But you can actually indeed
write a parallel partition
function that takes linear
your work in order log n span.
And then this would give you
an overall span bound of log
squared n.
And then if you take n log
n divided by log squared n,
that gives you an
overall parallelism of n
over log n, which is much
higher than order log n here.
And similarly, if you were
to implement a merge sort,
you would also need to make
sure that the merging routine is
implemented in
parallel, if you want
to see significant speedup.
So not only do you have to
execute the two recursive calls
in parallel, you also
need to make sure
that the merging portion of
the code is done in parallel.
Any questions on this example?
AUDIENCE: In the graph
that you had, sometimes
when you got to higher processor
numbers, it got jagged,
and so sometimes adding a
processor was making it slower.
What are some
reasons [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah so I believe
that's just due to noise,
because there's some noise
going on in the machine.
So if you ran it
enough times and took
the average or the median,
it should be always going up,
or it shouldn't be
decreasing, at least.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is also [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: So at one
level of recursion,
the partition function
takes order log n span.
You can show that there are
log n levels of recursion
in this quicksort algorithm.
I didn't go over the
details of this analysis,
but you can show that.
And then therefore,
the overall span
is going to be
order log squared.
And I can show you on
the board after class,
if you're interested, or I
can give you a reference.
Other questions?
So it turns out that in
addition to quicksort,
there are also many other
interesting practical parallel
algorithms out there.
So here, I've listed
a few of them.
And by practical, I mean
that the Cilk program running
on one processor is
competitive with the best
sequential program
for that problem.
And so you can see that I've
listed the work and the span
of merge sort here.
And if you implement
the merge and parallel,
the span of the
overall computation
would be log cubed n.
And log n divided by log cubed
n is n over log squared n.
That's the parallelism,
which is pretty high.
And in general, all
of these computations
have pretty high parallelism.
Another thing to note is that
these algorithms are practical,
because their work
bound is asymptotically
equal to the work of the
corresponding sequential
algorithm.
That's known as a work-efficient
parallel algorithm.
It's actually one of the goals
of parallel algorithm design,
to come up with work-efficient
parallel algorithms.
Because this means
that even if you
have a small number
of processors,
you can still be competitive
with a sequential algorithm
running on one processor.
And in the next
lecture, we actually
see some examples of
these other algorithms,
and possibly even ones
not listed on this slide,
and we'll go over the
work and span analysis
and figure out the parallelism.
So now I want to move on to talk
about some scheduling theory.
So I talked about these
computation dags earlier,
analyzed the work
and the span of them,
but I never talked about how
these different strands are
actually mapped to
processors at running time.
So let's talk a little bit
about scheduling theory.
And it turns out that
scheduling theory is actually
very general.
It's not just limited
to parallel programming.
It's used all over the place
in computer science, operations
research, and math.
So as a reminder, Cilk
allows the program
to express potential
parallelism in an application.
And a Cilk scheduler is
going to map these strands
onto the processors that you
have available dynamically
at runtime.
Cilk actually uses a
distributed scheduler.
But since the theory of
distributed schedulers
is a little bit
complicated, we'll
actually explore the
ideas of scheduling first
using a centralized scheduler.
And a centralized
scheduler knows everything
about what's going on
in the computation,
and it can use that to
make a good decision.
So let's first look at what
a centralized scheduler does,
and then I'll talk a
little bit about the Cilk
distributed scheduler.
And we'll learn more about that
in a future lecture as well.
So we're going to look
at a greedy scheduler.
And an idea of a
greedy scheduler
is to just do as
much as possible
in every step of
the computation.
So has anyone seen
greedy algorithms before?
Right.
So many of you have seen
greedy algorithms before.
So the idea is similar here.
We're just going to
do as much as possible
at the current time step.
We're not going to think
too much about the future.
So we're going to
define a ready strand
to be a strand where all of its
predecessors in the computation
dag have already executed.
So in this example
here, let's say
I already executed all
of these blue strands.
Then the ones
shaded in yellow are
going to be my ready
strands, because they
have all of their
predecessors executed already.
And there are two types of
steps in a greedy scheduler.
The first kind of step is
called a complete step.
And in a complete step, we
have at least P strands ready.
So if we had P equal to 3, then
we have a complete step now,
because we have 5 strands
ready, which is greater than 3.
So what are we going to
do in a complete step?
What would a greedy
scheduler do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so a
greedy scheduler would just
do as much as it can.
So it would just run any 3 of
these, or any P in general.
So let's say I picked
these 3 to run.
So it turns out that these are
actually the worst 3 to run,
because they don't enable
any new strands to be ready.
But I can pick those 3.
And then the
incomplete step is one
where I have fewer
than P strands ready.
So here, I have 2 strands
ready, and I have 3 processors.
So what would I do in
an incomplete step?
AUDIENCE: Just run through
the strands that are ready.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
just run all of them.
So here, I'm going to
execute these two strands.
And then we're going
to use complete steps
and incomplete steps to
analyze the performance
of the greedy scheduler.
There's a famous
theorem which was first
shown by Ron Graham
in 1968 that says
that any greedy
scheduler achieves
the following time bound--
T sub P is less than or equal
to T1 over P plus T infinity.
And you might recognize the
terms on the right hand side--
T1 is the work, and T
infinity is the span
that we saw earlier.
And here's a simple proof for
why this time bound holds.
So we can upper bound the
number of complete steps
in the computation by
T1 over P. And this
is because each complete step
is going to perform P work.
So after T1 over
P completes steps,
we'll have done all the
work in our computation.
So that means that the
number of complete steps
can be at most T1 over P.
So any questions on this?
So now, let's look at the
number of incomplete steps
we can have.
So the number of incomplete
steps we can have
is upper bounded by the
span, or T infinity.
And the reason why is that if
you look at the unexecuted dag
right before you execute
an incomplete step,
and you measure the span
of that unexecuted dag,
you'll see that once you
execute an incomplete step,
it's going to reduce the
span of that dag by 1.
So here, this is the span
of our unexecuted dag
that contains just
these seven nodes.
The span of this is 5.
And when we execute
an incomplete step,
we're going to process all the
roots of this unexecuted dag,
delete them from the
dag, and therefore, we're
going to reduce the length
of the longest path by 1.
So when we execute
an incomplete step,
it decreases the
span from 5 to 4.
And then the time
bound up here, T sub P,
is just upper bounded by the
sum of these two types of steps.
Because after you execute
T1 over P complete steps
and T infinity
incomplete steps, you
must have finished the
entire computation.
So any questions?
A corollary of this theorem
is that any greedy scheduler
achieves within a factor of 2
of the optimal running time.
So this is the optimal
running time of a scheduler
that knows everything and can
predict the future and so on.
So let's let TP star be
the execution time produced
by an optimal scheduler.
We know that TP star has to
be at least the max of T1
over P and T infinity.
This is due to the
work and span laws.
So it has to be at least
a max of these two terms.
Otherwise, we wouldn't have
finished the computation.
So now we can take
the inequality
we had before for the
greedy scheduler bound--
so TP is less than or equal
to T1 over P plus T infinity.
And this is upper bounded by
2 times the max of these two
terms.
So A plus B is upper bounded
by 2 times the max of A and B.
And then now, the max
of T1 over P and T
infinity is just upper
bounded by TP star.
So we can substitute
that in, and we
get that TP is upper
bounded by 2 times
TP star, which is the running
time of the optimal scheduler.
So the greedy scheduler
achieves within a factor
of 2 of the optimal scheduler.
Here's another corollary.
This is a more
interesting corollary.
It says that any greedy
scheduler achieves
near-perfect linear speedup
whenever T1 divided by T
infinity is greater
than or equal to P.
To see why this is true--
if we have that
T1 over T infinity
is much greater than P--
so the double arrows here
mean that the left hand
side is much greater than
the right hand side--
then this means that the span
is much less than T1 over P.
And the greedy scheduling
theorem gives us
that TP is less than or equal
to T1 over P plus T infinity,
but T infinity is much
less than T1 over P,
so the first term
dominates, and we have
that TP is approximately
equal to T1 over P.
And therefore, the speedup you
get is T1 over P, which is P.
And this is linear speedup.
The quantity T1
divided by P times T
infinity is known as
the parallel slackness.
So this is basically
measuring how much more
parallelism you have in a
computation than the number
of processors you have.
And if parallel
slackness is very high,
then this corollary
is going to hold,
and you're going to see
near-linear speedup.
As a rule of thumb, you usually
want the parallel slackness
of your program
to be at least 10.
Because if you have a
parallel slackness of just 1,
you can't actually amortize
the overheads of the scheduling
mechanism.
So therefore, you want
the parallel slackness
to be at least 10 when
you're programming in Cilk.
So that was the
greedy scheduler.
Let's talk a little bit
about the Cilk scheduler.
So Cilk uses a
work-stealing scheduler,
and it achieves an
expected running time
of TP equal to T1 over
P plus order T infinity.
So instead of just
summing the two terms,
we actually have a big O
in front of the T infinity,
and this is used to account for
the overheads of scheduling.
The greedy scheduler
I presented earlier--
I didn't account for any of
the overheads of scheduling.
I just assumed that it could
figure out which of the tasks
to execute.
So this Cilk
work-stealing scheduler
has this expected
time provably, so you
can prove this using
random variables and tail
bounds of distribution.
So Charles Leiserson
has a paper that
talks about how to prove this.
And empirically, we usually
see that TP is more like T1
over P plus T infinity.
So we usually don't see any
big constant in front of the T
infinity term in practice.
And therefore, we can get
near-perfect linear speedup,
as long as the number of
processors is much less than T1
over T infinity, the
maximum parallelism.
And as I said earlier, the
instrumentation in Cilkscale
will allow you to
measure the work and span
terms so that you can figure
out how much parallelism
is in your program.
Any questions?
So let's talk a little bit
about how the Cilk runtime
system works.
So in the Cilk runtime system,
each worker or processor
maintains a work deque.
Deque stands for
double-ended queue,
so it's just short for
double-ended queue.
It maintains a work
deque of ready strands,
and it manipulates the
bottom of the deck,
just like you would in a
stack of a sequential program.
So here, I have four
processors, and each one of them
have their own deques, and they
have these things on the stack,
these function calls,
saves the return address
to local variables, and so on.
So a processor can
call a function,
and when it calls
a function, it just
places that function's frame
at the bottom of its stack.
You can also spawn things, so
then it places a spawn frame
at the bottom of its stack.
And then these things
can happen in parallel,
so multiple processes can
be spawning and calling
things in parallel.
And you can also return
from a spawn or a call.
So here, I'm going to
return from a call.
Then I return from a spawn.
And at this point,
I don't actually
have anything left to do
for the second processor.
So what do I do now, when
I'm left with nothing to do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Take a [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the idea here
is to steal some work
from another processor.
So when a worker runs
out of work to do,
it's going to steal from the
top of a random victim's deque.
So it's going to pick one of
these processors at random.
It's going to roll some dice
to determine who to steal from.
And let's say that it
picked the third processor.
Now it's going to
take all of the stuff
at the top of the deque
up until the next spawn
and place it into its own deque.
And then now it has
stuff to do again.
So now it can continue
executing this code.
It can spawn stuff,
call stuff, and so on.
So the idea is that whenever a
worker runs out of work to do,
it's going to start
stealing some work
from other processors.
But if it always has enough
work to do, then it's happy,
and it doesn't need to steal
things from other processors.
And this is why MIT gives
us so much work to do,
so we don't have to steal
work from other people.
So a famous theorem says that
with sufficient parallelism,
workers steal very
infrequently, and this gives us
near-linear speedup.
So with sufficient
parallelism, the first term
in our running bound is going
to dominate the T1 over P term,
and that gives us
near-linear speedup.
Let me actually show you a
pseudoproof of this theorem.
And I'm allowed to
do a pseudoproof.
It's not actually a real
proof, but a pseudoproof.
So I'm allowed to do
this, because I'm not
the author of an
algorithms textbook.
So here's a pseudo proof.
AUDIENCE: Yet.
JULIAN SHUN: Yet.
So a processor is either working
or stealing at every time step.
And the total time that all
processors spend working
is just T1, because that's the
total work that you have to do.
And then when it's not
doing work, it's stealing.
And each steal has
a 1 over P chance
of reducing the span by 1,
because one of the processors
is contributing to the longest
path in the compilation dag.
And there's a 1 over
P chance that I'm
going to pick that
processor and steal
some work from that
processor and reduce
the span of my remaining
computation by 1.
And therefore, the
expected cost of all steals
is going to be order
P times T infinity,
because I have to steal P
things in expectation before I
get to the processor that
has the critical path.
And therefore, my overall costs
for stealing is order P times T
infinity, because I'm going
to do this T infinity times.
And since there
are P processors,
I'm going to divide
the expected time by P,
so T1 plus O of P times
T infinity divided by P,
and that's going to
give me the bound--
T1 over P plus order T infinity.
So this pseudoproof here ignores
issues with independence,
but it still gives
you an intuition
of why we get this
expected running time.
If you want to actually
see the full proof,
it's actually quite interesting.
It uses random variables and
tail bounds of distributions.
And this is the
paper that has this.
This is by Blumofe
and Charles Leiserson.
So another thing I
want to talk about
is that Cilk supports
C's rules for pointers.
So a pointer to a stack space
can be passed from a parent
to a child, but not from
a child to a parent.
And this is the same as the
stack rule for sequential C
programs.
So let's say I have this
computation on the left here.
So A is going to spawn
off B, and then it's
going to continue
executing C. In then C
is going to spawn
off D and execute E.
So we see on the right hand
side the views of the stacks
for each of the tasks here.
So A sees its own stack.
B sees its own
stack, but it also
sees A's stack, because
A is its parent.
C will see its own
stack, but again, it
sees A's stack, because
A is its parent.
And then finally, D and E,
they see the stack of C,
and they also see
the stack of A.
So in general, a task
can see the stack
of all of its ancestors
in this computation graph.
And we call this a
cactus stack, because it
sort of looks like a cactus,
if you draw this upside down.
And Cilk's cactus stack
supports multiple views
of the stacks in
parallel, and this
is what makes the parallel
calls to functions work in C.
We can also bound the stack
space used by a Cilk program.
So let's let S sub 1 be
the stack space required
by the serial execution
of a Cilk program.
Then the stack space required
by a P-processor execution
is going to be
bounded by P times S1.
So SP is the stack
space required
by a P-processor execution.
That's less than or
equal to P times S1.
Here's a high-level proof
of why this is true.
So it turns out that the
work-stealing algorithm in Cilk
maintains what's called
the busy leaves property.
And this says that each of the
existing leaves that are still
active in the computation
dag have some work
they're executing on it.
So in this example
here, the vertices
shaded in blue and purple--
these are the ones that are in
my remaining computation dag.
And all of the gray nodes
have already been finished.
And here-- for
each of the leaves
here, I have one processor
on that leaf executing
the task associated with it.
So Cilk guarantees this
busy leaves property.
And now, for each
of these processors,
the amount of stack
space it needs
is it needs the stack
space for its own task
and then everything above
it in this computation dag.
And we can actually bound
that by the stack space needed
by a single processor execution
of the Cilk program, S1,
because S1 is just the
maximum stack space we need,
which is basically the
longest path in this graph.
And we do this for
every processor.
So therefore, the upper
bound on the stack space
required by P-processor
execution is just P times S1.
And in general, this is a
quite loose upper bound,
because you're not
necessarily going
all the way all the way
down in this competition dag
every time.
Usually you'll be much higher
in this computation dag.
So any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In practice,
how much work is stolen?
JULIAN SHUN: In practice, if you
have enough parallelism, then
you're not actually
going to steal
that much in your algorithm.
So if you guarantee that
there's a lot of parallelism,
then each processor is going
to have a lot of its own work
to do, and it doesn't need
to steal very frequently.
But if your
parallelism is very low
compared to the
number of processors--
if it's equal to the
number of processors,
then you're going to spend
a significant amount of time
stealing, and the overheads
of the work-stealing algorithm
are going to show up
in your running time.
AUDIENCE: So I
meant in one steal--
like do you take
half of the deque,
or do you take one
element of the deque?
JULIAN SHUN: So the standard
Cilk work-stealing scheduler
takes everything at
the top of the deque up
until the next spawn.
So basically that's a strand.
So it takes that.
There are variants that
take more than that,
but the Cilk
work-stealing scheduler
that we'll be
using in this class
just takes the top strand.
Any other questions?
So that's actually
all I have for today.
If you have any
additional questions,
you can come talk
to us after class.
And remember to meet with
your MITPOSSE mentors soon.